Speaker 1: Fox News is in somewhat of a panic in
the wake of the Wisconsin Supreme Court election
results that once again highlighted the strength
and passion behind abortion rights, democracy
and other crucial issues, and how the Republican
stance on those things, the actions they've been
taking, is just not popular, especially as will
be talked about here. The younger generations
get more active in politics and there's
different approaches. I'll show you a couple
here. Some I'm just recognizing how these issues
directly have impacted election results. And I've
seen kind of here and their calls for Republicans
to moderate themselves. Otherwise they're going to
keep losing. But some do. What I'm about to show
you here with Kellyanne Conway, what she's doing,
which is come up with a rather incoherent and cope
copy way to deal with the fact that. The modern
conservative ideology just isn't popular with the
majority of Americans. And that's why we saw the
underwhelming midterm results. That's why we saw
and especially because the Republican Party is
being driven by this MAGA ideology and the radical
stances on things like abortion rights. That's
why we've seen when abortion rights are on the
ballot or when the directly tied to a candidate,
abortion rights prevail. As I said, the
Wisconsin election results and others and this
is how Kellyanne Conway synthesized this reality.
Speaker 5: We can't be beaten on this policy wise.
I think we've already won the policy arguments on
the economy, on education, on a number of issues.
I think we've got some work to do on the young
people who think differently on abortion, perhaps,
or guns or climate change. But even there, the
Democrats messages are usually cynical. The place
I'm really the thing I'm really concerned about.
Speaker 1: So cynical. Let's protect
women's rights.
Speaker 5: With this,
Laura, is that the left becomes a turnout machine
with young people because influencers have this
domino effect, lemming like effect of people
just all then wanting to be part of the same
crowd. And if they succeed in that way, we're not
doing a great job competing for ballots. We're
just competing for votes. Our candidates lost
the early voting miserably last time. I mean,
someone like Dr. Oz lost the early vote to
John Fetterman by over 4 to 1. So we need to
compete for ballots, not just voters and not just
minds. And I think they're trying to do that with
these influencers. I have faith in the American
people. I think they'll catch on to this and say,
I want a policy argument. Well, Kellyanne, I think
you raise an excellent point, though. And it seems
like the Republicans are always playing catch
up, even though it's obvious what happened last
time with the early voting. And, you know, all
these folks who run the RNC and other, you know,
other, I guess, Republican outlets that are
supposed to be getting this right this time,
what are they doing? Are they, you know, getting
their own ballot harvesting operation going where
it's legal or are they, you know, lining up their
own channels for early voting? Is that going to
happen this time? Do you have confidence in that?
Speaker 1: So they're trying to make this absurd
distinction between. And we'll get
to another clip here from Fox. But
between ballots and votes and they're saying
Democrats go and they harvest ballots and they
win through the ballot game. And we were just
focusing on votes and nuanced policy discussions.
I haven't seen policy coming in significant,
nuanced, meaningful policy conversations coming
from Republicans, at least the driving core of the
Republican Party being MAGA in a very long time,
maybe ever when it comes to that particular
movement. But. There's this perception that
the increased votes or the success in different
elections and this is slightly different than
the it's different than the stolen election
conspiracy theory, but it kind of is a child
of that where there's something malicious and
mysterious going on with the Democratic Party. And
that's why more young voters are supporting them
or that's why they were successful in the states
in this election or that election, or that's
why abortion rights are impacting elections
so significantly. That's why people care about
democracy, all that. And it's just not true.
It's not ballots, force votes. Ballots are the
way the way that we vote. And more people just
vote in favor of some of these Democratic policies
in a lot of situations, especially younger voters.
But even they try to craft this narrative. That.
It's just the Gen Z that Republicans are unpopular
with, which they are very unpopular with Gen Z.
But the radical stances on abortion, gun control,
democracy with the attempts to overturn the
election results and others are unpopular
with the majority of just America generally. And
still Gen Z is a very small portion of the voting
population. So it's mostly not Gen Z. And still
you're very unpopular and find ways to eke out
victories of course, and still have a lot of
power. But generally the ideology is just not
something people can get behind and it's not
going to consistently be supported, especially as.
I said the younger generations get more involved
in politics. And so for Kellyanne Conway, it's
less about harvest. You can only be successful in
ballot harvesting, which is just getting a third
party to take someone's ballot to the polling
place. So if it's an elderly person, they can
have a family member or something. Take
that ballot to the polling place for them.
But it's only successful if you actually
have people to fill out the ballot who
are real voters who actually want to support
the Republican Party. And that's your issue
for sure. Next moment here
responding to these results.
Speaker 3: Check that out. Bret, you
follow these results in Wisconsin.
Hmm. Interesting. Here's what we found
for the Gen z vote. In the 2020 midterms,
they went 7721 for democrats. And now there's
this you know, this is not a five alarm fire,
but it's a concern among Republicans as to how
they get young people to vote for them, especially
with the issue of abortion, more or less on the
ballots in so many different state races. This is
what Kellyanne Conway told us just last hour here.
Speaker 1: And there's more. Kellyanne Conway But
I have an idea. It's going to be it's going
to sound a little goofy, a little strange.
And I'm not normally giving
strategic advice to Republicans,
but I'm going to do it here.
You can take it or leave it.
My wild idea for not alienating certain
voting populations on the issue of abortion.
Is to have a less radical view on abortion.
That would be my advice to the Republican Party.
But definitely interesting to see different
ways in which he's being more authentic and
recognizing just the Republicans have a stance
that is popular among so many populations. What
Kellyanne Conway is saying, it's a ballot versus
votes game and we will continue to watch it all
move forward. Make sure you subscribe
to me on YouTube at Luke Beesley.